when an extravagant party at sea hosted
by spoiled socialite Oliver Queen was
attacked by pirates he eluded capture
and used his boat to retaliate against
his would-be kidnappers his indifference
to archery lessons proved fatal when his
attack triggered the Pirates explosives
killing 20 and throwing Oliver into the
Pacific Ocean marooned on a desert
island Queen honed his bow skills to
survive pledging his life to making
things right and donning the mantle of
Green Arrow Green Arrow is an adaptable
marksman capable of devastating damage
and elusive maneuvers
Green Arrow can switch between three
stances that enhance his mobility and
ranged attacks when used each of his
first three skills provides a unique
stance bonus it remains in effect until
a different stance altering skill is
executed
when switching to a new stance Green
Arrow's next basic attack is empowered
with a unique Arabic
his passive is adaptable ammo when green
arrow uses super foam arrows ballistic
arrows or thermite arrows he gains a
brief attack speed boost and his
Ultimates cooldown is reduced use super
foam arrows to rush in the target
direction the arrow bonus will cause the
basic attack to reduce an enemy's move
speed
the super foam stamps grants bonus
movespeed
although taking damage will temporarily
suppress it the arrow bonus from
ballistic arrows makes his next basic
attack deal extra attack damage and the
ballistic stance gives him attack
penetration the arrow bonus from
thermite arrows will cause his next
basic attack to attach a bomb the bomb
explodes after a few seconds or if a
second bomb is applied dealing damage
around the target the thermite stance
will cause any target killed by green
arrow to explode and damage nearby
targets
bullseye is Green Arrow's ultimate and
is available at level one
activate bullseye to begin charging this
powerful shot while charging green arrow
is unable to use basic attacks and it's
moot speed is reduced the total range
and damage of bullseye will grow the
longer the shot is charged the charging
bullseye for too long will cause it to
fail and begin its cooldown returning a
portion of spent will activate bullseye
a second time to fire the shot passes
through and damages drones only stopping
when it hits an enemy champion
however if green arrow was in the
ballistic stance when firing bullseye it
will pass through and damage both drones
and champions otherwise bullseye will
apply green arrows most recent arrow
bonus to the first enemy champion if
hits
use the rush from super foam arrows to
escape from dangerous situations or to
chase down an enemy you have the bonus
move speed from super Foam stance is
also great for faster map travel
thermite arrows provides excellent
harass especially when paired with
bullseye when defending your long-range
and agility can be used to poke install
enemy captures of power relays and
control points to deal high damage
quickly basic attack after using
ballistic or thermite arrow and then
follow up with bullseye applying a
double dose of arrow bonus green arrow
excels with artifacts that provide
attacked image lifesteal and critical
chance if the enemy team builds attack
armor consider picking up coda blade or
atomic axe in the early match soultaker
katana or cheetahs claw can help you
sustain your lean presence artifacts
with critical chance like Joe chills
revolver and Zeiss goggles help maximize
your damage output a little defense goes
a long way once your dishing out the
damage for several seconds after being
placed green arrow surveillance cameras
can see through stealth revealing enemy
cameras and champions this is especially
useful to counter surprise attacks by
champions with stealth like Gaslight
Catwoman and nightmare Batman
bring an arrow for every occasion as
green arrow